I mean in Ronda Rousey's case
it was also, it was very, yeah,
her mom was a world judo
champion and mom was a pieced.
She's had an interesting path
I think probably. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm wondering how much she loves the WWE.
I wonder,
I always wonder when a person is like an
elite athlete at the highest level one,
a real one.
If they,
they still enjoy doing that cause
I think she enjoyed it though.
I think she was a fan of it before
she ever got involved. Yeah. She,
I think she actually enjoyed
pro wrestling, you know,
and she things even though it's scripted,
obviously flying off of an
into and around athletic,
but it's scripted. Yes. It's
not competition. But then again,
you can only get knocked
unconscious so many times.
You can only get fucked up so many times
and she got fucked up two fights in a
row really bad. The Holly
Holm K, which was ruthless,
that was brewed on then Amanda Nunez
just punched her face in for 48 seconds.
It was horrific. Yeah. That was hard
to watch. I like to watch. I mean,
I don't like to watch a really big
guys punch each other and women,
I don't know why,
like when guys are a little smaller,
it's easier to watch as long as they're
not kicking themselves in the head.
I'm just saying,
so the big scary ones like heavyweights
dropping bombs on the Japanese go,
oh my God, that just, that guy took eight
years off. That guy's, you know? Yeah.
It's definitely different.
And you do notice it like a,
there's certain heavyweights and they hit
guys and they get knocked unconscious,
whether it's Frances in Gando or steep
Daimyo chits are these big guys and they
slammed, someone's like, oh my God.
That's what I mean. Like I watch that.
I don't actually, I mean violence. I
know it's sport, but for me it's, oh,
it's violent. It is, yeah. It's a,
it is a very dangerous path that you
have to know when to get off and more,
I don't know if I would say more so
than other combat sports, but yep,
it makes sense. All of them,
all of them have a path.
But I think very specifically,
MMA has,
you have to be really careful because
the consequences are so great.
There's not enough padding.
And those gloves are tiny little things.
You could also get kicked. He could get
kneed in the face, elbowed in the face,
and once you've realized the Chin starts
going and your reflexes start going and
you're, you're slowing down, like you
got to get out now you got to get out.
And sometimes they don't get
the proper advice, you know?
And sometimes they don't
know what else to do.
They don't have anywhere else to go. And
that goes back to, yeah, I was talking,
I tell,
talked to a lawyer about that because
we have tons of friends in organized
sports stuff.
Like you have to be drafted or coach,
the team has to pick you up or, you
know, whatever. And I say to him like,
how fortunate are you
that you're in a sport
like other athletes, like a snowboarder
or whatever, that you can go, yeah,
you can go out. Yeah, you
want a ride, you can go ride.
Nobody is dictating to you right.